اخبر العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم عشرات القتلى والمصابين بحريق في
حفل زفاف في محافظه نينوى العراق المتحدث
باسم الداخليه يقول ان الحريق ناجم عن
العاب ناريه وغياب لاجراءات السلامه
ومستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي يقولوا
للجزيره ان هناك تحقيقات واجراءات تنفيذيه
واداريه لضمان عدم تكرار حوادث كهذه
الرئاسه الفرنسيه تؤكد مغادره سفيرها
والخارجيه الفرنسيه تعلن وصول سفيرها الى
باريس في حين يؤكد المتحدث باسم المجلس
العسكري للجزيره عدم طلب قوه بديله للجنود
الفرنسيه
نحو 50000 نازح من ارمن اقليم كنبه يصلون
الى ارمينيا اذربيجان تعلن ان العمليه
العسكريه في الاقليم تسببت في مقتل قرابه
200 من جنودها وتقول ان الفرصه سانحه
للتطبيع معايريفان في الوقت الذي تدعو فيه
واشنطن باكو للسماح بدخول بعثه مراقبه
دوليه الى الاقليم
مؤسسه ريسيتك الاستراليه للابحاث تقول ان
منصه اكس تعطلت خاصيه تسمح للمستخدمين
بالابلاغ عن معلومات مضلله متعلقه
بالانتخابات مشيره الى ان المستخدمين ما
زال بامكانهم الابلاغ عن منشورات تتضمن
ترويجا للعنف او خطابا للكراهيه الى
اللقاء